- [Male Interviewer] All right, Valerie.
Valerie, tell me about your life.
Where'd you grow up? Where you are from?
- [Valerie] Boyle Heights.
- East LA.
And you grew up with both parents?
- Just my mom.
- Just your mom.
And how was your childhood?
- I guess okay.
My mom was pretty good at raising us.
I just remember being
molested by my brother.
- Your brother?
- Yeah.
- Older brother?
- What age were you?
- I guess he was 13 years,
going through puberty
if I really recall.
And I was like, what, three
years younger than him.
So it was about nine, 10
years old if I recall.
And I guess I try to blank it
out all these years, I went
to my mom and then found out about it.
You know, when he had a baby,
I reacted, I reacted out
but my uncle messing,
you know, touching us
cause it was six sisters and one brother.
- So your uncle too?
- Yeah, my uncle.
And I make it, I guess
that's all I can remember.
I mean, it was pretty good.
You know, my dad scolded us a
lot, I was one of those when
they say not to do it, I did it.
- So your dad was around?
- He was around for a while,
but he was an alcoholic.
So he was more or less out, you know,
like out of the picture, you know.
He was even paralyzed for a while.
I remember us trying to take care of him
and my mom got tired of him, you know.
So he was around, but not really.
It was mom that raised us.
I give my mom all the credit.
- And then where did you go from there?
- Real young, I remember
getting hooked on cocaine at 15
but already like about
fifth or sixth grade
which I don't know how old I was then;
I was already hanging
around with older people,
hypes, PCP smokers, you know.
I was just, I liked the
the crazy lifestyle.
My mom never used.
And my dad was an alcoholic.
So I don't know where I went wrong.
My uncles, all my uncles
and aunts were gang faded.
And you know, but I just chose that life.
- Did you grow up in gangs?
- Yeah. I'm from Metal
Flats. I'm from Flats.
- Oh, I see.
- Yeah, gang flow real heavy.
I got in young.
I got in, I think in the
sixth grade on there,
fifth, sixth grade.
And I started doing cocaine,
the cocaine what's...
I had a baby.
I had my first daughter
and my mom took her
because of me, you know,
running in and out of the house.
I don't blame her.
And I'm just smoking.
I remember learning how
to prostitute right away.
You know, somebody telling
me how to do this, you know
be in the streets.
And I thought it was easy money
better than robbing and hurting people.
So I did that and it was just easy money
real easy money, which it was, you know.
You got your serial killers out there.
You got your people that beat you up
and rape you and you have a hard life.
I remember going through
a lot of gangs, taxing you
you know, trying to
get your money and just
just getting high and living a crazy life.
It really didn't bother me.
I was one of those crazy people.
- Have you had interactions
with serial killers?
- Yes. When was young I was
in Evergreen in Cesar Chavez.
I was like, I think I
was about 20, 21 around,
somewhere around there.
They were telling us
to get off the street.
Wow.
I remember going with him
and pulled out a big machete,
my neck and raped me.
But the whole time he was raping me off,
I have such a foul mouth.
I was like, "Is your dick too small?"
You know, I got, I kept
feeling it. It was in my pussy.
I was being a real smart ass.
I couldn't, I was just testing,
I'm always testing people.
I don't know why.
- He had a machete to your neck?
- Yes. He kept telling me,
"Shut the fuck up, bitch".
And I just kept testing him
and testing him when he was doing it.
I mean, it's funny and then it's not
because I was still alive.
I remember him getting my aunt.
Slicing my aunt from here to here.
Three women ended up
missing at that point when
this happened to me, I
don't know what year it is.
I can't tell you stuff like that.
But I was about 20, 21.
When he was done I remember him saying,
"Get the fuck off the car".
I go, "Fuck no, you take me
back to where you took me".
I was, I was just one
of those crazy people.
- You were 20 years old?
- Yes, I was. I did this when I was young.
And then I can tell you another incident.
I was pregnant in a
car, which I have marks.
I have a lot of scars on me.
Which I could tell, a
stab here, a stab here.
But, I remember being in there
and it was so embarrassing
because it was getting morning
and the guy was just,
I was giving him a head
and his butt was going
towards the windshield and
I was all paranoid because I did cocaine.
That was the only thing I ever did.
I tried other drugs.
I don't drink, I don't
smoke just the cocaine.
And he paid me.
And when he was done, I
just felt something weird.
So when I looked at him, he
had a knife to my throat.
He goes, "Give me back the money, bitch".
And I was like, "Oh, hell no".
After everything I went through,
he wants his money back.
It's not going to work out.
So I grabbed the knife and I pulled it
down and I remember him
hitting me, which look
I don't feel nothing.
I'm like try it again.
And his eyes were like oh hell.
I go, "You got the wrong bitch.
Give me the fucking weapon,
give me some of money you
got in your pocket now".
He swung at me again
which I don't feel nothing in the head.
So, you know, and then I'm just,
and he looked like, Oh shit.
And I said, you know,
"Don't ever come over here
doing that to us".
And I ended up holding the knife so tight.
I remember a lady passing.
I said, "I'm gonna take this shit,
"shove it up your ass
and I'm gonna twist it".
And he kept socking my head.
But I was like, damn, wow why you keep,
I'm not feeling nothing.
All the blows been done
to me, I don't feel shit.
So I was, you know,
what the hell you doing
but it freaked him out more.
So, "Get out my car".
But I wouldn't pull the knife.
When I finally got off I
remember saying, like, "Fuck"
you know, like, and I
have blood on my hand
and I was praying,
(inaudible) hurt my baby.
And, but just incidents, like
that one just after another,
I just didn't care.
I was like a walking dead, walking zombie.
People look at me, which you, said,
I don't look like I'm part of the street.
I've been through hell and back. Big time.
And then when I came just, there's stories
I could go on and on.
Just leaving my kids.
I already have three, my
Darlene, Jessica and Adam.
My mom had them.
I tried to take care
of my son. I couldn't.
He was in the street for
a while; homeless with me.
My (inaudible) was against it
sometimes, but they love me.
I love my kids.
I have a good relationship with them.
And sometimes, you know, they act up
they're mad at mom and
they know about my life.
They never approve of it
but they're like, mom, hustles.
I never asked nobody for shit
and I take care of myself.
And when I came downtown, I lost my house.
Obama gave me a house.
I have a beautiful home.
People that got me Facebook is why.
I lost it and I came
down here to Skid Row.
This is a hardest I've
ever had in my whole life.
Sometimes I feel like I'm
going to die down here.
I got stabbed recently.
I got skin graft.
I was in the hospital for a whole month.
They tried to rob me and it
wouldn't let go of the money.
I figured I worked hard for it.
I'm not going to give it to anybody.
And I don't bug.
I don't rob.
I don't do nothing.
I try to carry myself real respectfully.
But the more you're nice the more
they take advantage of you.
So down here, when
somebody finally told me
they stabbed me here.
So they got me right by the heart.
That took a part of me.
That changed me from being a nice person.
I have like a wall up
which I always had walls
up, but more, more.
And groove.
A lot of people down here know me.
I didn't, they all attacked me.
They all tried to break
me, recently in the motel.
I have a bump, here.
They bashed my face into the
radiator, try to crack my neck.
And I'm still standing.
I'm still standing.
Somebody just socked me
because they're high.
You know, they hit me in the face.
But I'm just one of
those Like just tell me,
why did, what did I do,
and I'll check myself.
And I eat it, and I walk up to them,
stupid crack kills the brain too.
I walk right up to it.
He hit me so hard that
I actually felt stars.
Cause I don't feel nothing, remember.
That's how hard the blow was.
Today, I don't know what's
going to happen to me.
I don't know what's going to become of me
when trying to get into a program.
Just, you know
like I know there's
different things out there.
I got seven kids, nine grandkids.
I want something better.
- Did you go to prison?
- Dear Allah, all my
twenties was in prison.
Close to 16 years.
- Oh wow, what kind was it?
- You name it. I done it.
And like I have mayhem, which wasn't me.
I have murder cases, 187s, I have,
I have more of that stuff that
and all I did was
prostitute and sell my ass.
I smoked crack and sold my ass.
But I have been around
places, wrong places, guns.
You know, like I have bad
charges, but just being
around bad people, I guess
you get caught up, you know?
But then I have battery
on a security recently,
which it wasn't me.
You know, she started it.
But just normal person trying to live.
Basically.
- Where are you staying at?
- I'm homeless and scared.
- You're on the streets.
- I'm on the streets.
I just got out of detox right now.
Just been there a day.
You know, this is the way
look I lost 67 pounds.
I'm real skinny right now.
- Do your parents...do your
kids know that you're down here?
- Yes. A lot of people tell
me to get out of Skid Row.
You know, just my kids just
got their life together.
They just got section eight.
I got nine grandkids.
I don't want to fuck their life up.
I did enough damage as it is.
So I try to do this on my own
but I know my family
has my back, you know.
I just hope I make it out a live.
- Is your mom still around?
- My mom's around. My dad's around too.
But he's living his
life, he's old already.
- Have you talked to your mom?
- Not recently, but I hope soon.
On June, I lost a little
boy behind a murder case.
Angel.
June 8th, I've met him for the first time.
He came back into my life.
I came back then I seen him.
I always had faith I was
going to see him again.
And I did.
So good things are happening
and bad things well.
But just trying to hold on
trying to hang in there as best I can say.
- All right Valerie, thank
you so much for talking to me.
- You're welcome.
- Good luck to you.
- Thank you.